foreign
[Music]
let's roll the cameras another game
and black against 1396.
okay
so obviously we play the Sicilian
and we are still at the stage when well
a lot of players
play either anti-sicilians or they play
you know offbeat Sicilians such as
Knight F3 and Bishop C4 like I as I call
it the Italian
against the Sicilian although I think
the official name is the bowdler attack
here we're facing Knight B1 to C3 which
is the uh jumping off point to a variety
of different anti-sicilians you might
recognize the Grand Prix attack which is
the move f4 on move three there is also
the closed Sicilian which is the king
side Bishop fianchetto on the next move
and of course Knight C3 does not
necessarily preclude the possibility
that white goes back into the open
Sicilian against virtually any of
Black's moves white responds in many
cases with Knight G1 to F3 and then
plays D4 and then gets back into an open
Sicilian so because we are accelerated
Dragon players in this speedrun it makes
perfect sense for us to
uh to roll out and corresponding setup
as we've done before and that setup of
course starts with the move Knight C6
now I'll talk a little bit after the
game and I've done this before about
which move you should play based on
what variation of the open Sicilian you
play if you're a night or player you
actually don't want to go Knight C6 here
this is a pretty well known idea because
white can what's called move order you
into a system into a sicilian that you
don't play
by flipping back into an open Sicilian
if that makes sense and of course in the
night or if the Knight doesn't come out
to C6 so I'll expand on that a little
bit Bishop B5 is the third major
anti-sicilian variation I don't think
this has a name
um but this line has been around for for
decades now and it's a it's a pretty
it's like a faceless anti Sicilian it
can be a very dangerous line if black is
not pretty familiar with uh the theory
black can get a bad position
positionally and tactically
it it resembles a rosalimo but of course
it's inferior to rosalimo uh in the
Rosalie mother is a knight on F3 and the
function that that Knight fulfills is of
course it protects the D4 Square so the
principled move here and the move that
we are going to play and this is also
the response to Bishop G5 and the
trumpowski right it's a pretty common
General type of move across many
openings and that is of course Knight C6
to D4 and yes removing the same piece
more than once true but in this case
it's pretty clear that this Knight is a
pretty Monster piece and we're also
pressuring the bishop so the main line
here for white is Bishop B5 to C4 Knight
F3 is a sideline and I'll make a honest
confession straight away this is not a
sideline that I remember the theory of
very well so we're just gonna have to
make some stuff up here and that's kind
of going to be fun
now the first move I think is quite
obvious the reason we play Knight D4 is
to eliminate the bishop on B5 this move
doesn't make much sense it just allows
white to bring their Queen out and then
we're not developed at all so we might
as well give this Knight up for the
bishop so we take the bishop and now the
vast majority of people this might be a
move we play as well I think would
instinctively play A6 here right A6 of
course is a natural human instinct then
it pushes the Knight back to C3
but I would push back on the idea that
A6 is necessarily forced right and it's
it's worthwhile to explore these
instincts you often have because they
can actually be wrong the Knight on B5
it's not all that dangerous as a
standalone piece right so we actually
could play a move such as D6 or we could
play even a move such as Knight G8 to F6
trying to exploit the fact that the pawn
on e4 is temporarily undefended and
Knight F6 is quite an interesting move
here as far as I vaguely remember
um so let me take a moment here to think
about what we want to play Asics is the
is the natural move and then we can
transpose into a bit of a knight or
setup by playing A6 and then D6 we
actually could get into like a souped up
night or if white ends up playing D4
which I think he very well might and
because I am a night off player myself
this is something people might not know
I played the Knight of Sicilian from the
time that I was about 16 1700 to the
time that I was a 2500 GM so I played
the nighter for many many years and that
is the setup I feel most comfortable
with and so for that reason we are going
to play A6 chase the night away
and of course after the game we will
explore the theory we'll do some
research and we will figure out the best
setup against Bishop B5 and now
uh we're gonna roll out the pawn and put
it on D6 and as we predicted white plays
D4
and we get uh it's wrong to call this an
open Sicilian this is still an
anti-sicilian because white lacks the
light squirt Bishop so fundamentally the
position is quite different from uh any
night Earth that we could get and here
we don't have much of a choice we don't
want to allow white to take on C5 and
favorably trade Queens drawing our King
out of its shell so of course we want to
play CD and our opponent clearly going
down a theoretical line I think we're
still stuck in theory now
I could talk about this position for
ages but in the interest of time I'm
going to hit on the important points
there are going to be a couple of moves
in the next two moves which I think the
people watching you might not fully
understand them you might have
objections to them and I promise that
I'll expand more after the game but I
want to keep some time on my clock this
seems to be a dangerous opponent
so what is Black's fundamental issue in
this position we have the bishop here
which is great our Pawn structure is
very healthy the issue is that we lack
development right we are seriously
behind in development and that's always
a dangerous moment right we don't have a
single piece developed so you might say
okay well let's let's get started let's
go Knight F6 right the issue with Knight
F6 is that white could actually strike
in the center with E5 now what happens
in that variation well after E5 we play
D take C5
white traits queens and then takes back
on E5 with the Knight attacking the F7
pawn and even though the Queens are off
the board it doesn't mean that White's
initiative suddenly subsides if you
visualize that position you'll see that
it's quite unpleasant for black we have
to move the king back to E8 and then
white gets the bishop out and that just
seems like a pretty unpleasant position
so we need to do something about the
possibility of white playing E5 and yes
this something involves a serious
positional concession but I vote we make
a positional concession rather than get
crushed in some end game where we're not
developed developing any pieces what am
I talking well definitely not F6 that is
way too big of a concession way too big
of a consumption let's beat them to it
and this is a pretty typical move in
certain night or flight positions and
I'll introduce a couple of other
examples to You Queen before something
tells me at this point either this is
ridiculous level of preparation or our
opponent is uh just bsing something
tells me he's not pissing Queen before
actually looks like a great move this is
a very high level move so yeah I'm
getting out theoried but that's okay
we're gonna figure it out
so you might see the move D5 and assume
that it's good for black but we're not
ready to play D5 right we're not we we
would be biting off way more than we can
show after D5
um the queen will drop back to B3 and
then our E5 Pawn is going to be hanging
I actually don't even want to calculate
that line I think we can do without D5
so we lack development we have also
created a major weakness on the D5
Square so we've got a lot of problems to
solve here
um and the issue
with the move Knight F6 is that white
brings the bishop out to G5
and this is a classic positional idea I
call this the Smith lav idea and I'll
show you the stem game after we finish
basically it's very simple to understand
why it takes the Knight away and then
sticks his own Knight on D5 and that's
the last thing we want we want to be
able to contest the D5 square with our
Knight
so unfortunately this is not a move I
really want to play but I think we have
to play it starting with Bishop E7 puts
a Band-Aid over the problem but after
Bishop E7 Knight F6 again White's gonna
play Bishop G5 I think we have to
eliminate White's control over the G5
square and play another pawn move I know
we're kind of you know we're we're
testing the limits of the strategy but
our structure is still very
fundamentally sound right everything is
defending each other yes we have a
weakness on D5 but I don't feel like
we're getting checkmated here right
concretely I feel like we're finally
ready to bring our pieces out and once
we do we've got a lot of hidden Assets
in this position which can start coming
out if our opponent doesn't manage to
continue the initiative and you know
conducting the initiative is one of the
hardest skills in chess and it's a skill
that you know many GMS don't aren't
perfect at Bishop E3 so our opponent
develops the bishop and finally we can
start developing our own piece so
without a second thought we play the
move Knight F6
you might notice that white has Bishop
to B6 here which our opponent might play
but this is not I think such a scary
move we bring our Queen up to D7 and
that's a little bit awkward because it
blocks the development of the light
squared Bishop but the queen can park
itself on C6 later to make space for the
bishop so Bishop B6 played
we could also play Queen E7 but that's
actually far more Awkward what is our
priority here well our priority as you
should understand is to develop your
um oh actually wait there's a crazy idea
here for white
huh let me think about this for a second
wow I'm speechless
there's a crazy idea that's making me
speechless
and it's actually working
um so this is in response to Queen D7
the crazy idea is Rook D1 and if we play
Queen C6 there we're walking into Knight
F3 takes E5
de5 and then Rook d8 checkmate
so we have to solve that problem and
this is this is beyond my pay grade I'll
be totally honest
okay well we have ways to solve that
problem let's go Queen D7 anyway
white can also Castle Queen inside which
is a super high level move
okay
um
yeah this is this is not great I'm I'm
getting outplayed here
so what we have to do is move the queen
we have to move the queen because white
is threatening Knight takes C5 but where
do we move it well we have to move it on
a square such that the queen defends E5
does that make sense uh otherwise white
will play Knight takes E5 and deliver
checkman idea so the only square that I
see is actually E6 it's not a great
Square because we're still blocking our
light squared Bishop but as long as we
manage to Castle I feel like we'll be
okay
I am very worried about the move Bishop
to C7 here
um I feel like that's what a GM would
play
and I think that forces us to get into a
pawn down end game
I mean it's it's not great but it's
something and I have to say this this
bishop B5 line in my defense the reason
I don't really know it that well is
because I am a knight or flare and for
my whole life I have avoided this line
by playing D6 in this position in
retrospect maybe we should have done
that but I'm offering an official
accelerated Dragon repertoire and I will
have gaps in that repertoire myself so I
think that's part of the fun right we do
research and I fill those gaps myself
okay
um Bishop C7 played
oh I can't even wait no I can't play D5
um we have to play D5 because otherwise
white takes on D6
so we have to try this move by hooker by
crook like we we have to attempt this
move
um and let's see how white responds in
this position
I'm worried about just Knight takes D5
just Knight takes D5
and
that's basically resignable after Knight
takes D5
yeah yeah in this position because I
can't take the queen it's mate
okay that was some bait for a stream
snack okay Queen A5
yeah I'm starting to smell a rat
okay let's go D4
let's see how our opponent responds in
this position
so D4 now this could still be Theory and
if it is then I stand corrected
something tells me it's not so okay
there's nothing we can do
let's set everything aside we've been in
the situation before in the speeder on
and I haven't been happy with how I've
handled it my request to everyone in the
chat is that we basically treat this
like a normal game we do our best
and if I lose you know we'll check the
game
if I believe he's cheating I will let
you know but right now we have this game
I can still try to play the best moves
and that would be in the best Spirit of
what we're doing the speed run doesn't
matter what if we're playing Magnus
right
it's completely lost for black at this
point but white still needs to find a
couple of moves here
and the move that I think white needs to
find is Knight F3 takes E5 the problem
is that we can't take the Knight that's
the issue
um and we the reason we can't take the
Knight is because of Rook dhek King E7
and queen C5 with mate
so as black here there's only one thing
that we can do and let's try to Castle
kingside so the only move here is Bishop
to E7 we're going to have to give up
both of our Center pawns and castle
yeah this is the strongest opponent
we've not only have we ever faced in the
sooner but this is the strongest one I
have ever faced period I don't remember
the last time I got crushed like this
was maybe when I was like 1600.
um but let's see how our opponent
handles the ensuing complications let's
give him the benefit of the doubt and
let's assume that all of this was theory
that this is some deep chessable
preparation
um now comes the moment when our
opponent really has to demonstrate some
technique the game isn't far from Over
the game is not over
um we can we can still hold this you've
seen me survive crazier positions
so we're gonna give our opponent the
benefit of the doubt
and I'm going to try to outline how I
try to survive dead lost positions which
is another important topic in the
meantime and our opponent finally taking
his time that's a good sign that's a
good sign
so what's happening in this position
well
I I would have taken on D4 as probably
would 99 of people in the chat within
like two or three seconds
our opponent is contemplating other
candidate moves I assume
there is a crazy idea that white has
here I won't quite reveal it but if it's
played I will confirm that that was the
idea
so let's see what our opponent comes up
with here he's now taken quite a while
Queen A4 check
so it's a check right and we can do a
bunch of things here I don't want to go
king f8 that's just way too ugly
we can play Bishop to D7
but then that allows simplification we
don't want simplification because we're
down a bunch of Pawns
probably we should play the move B5
but then white has Knight takes B5
a takes B5 and The Rook on a it hangs at
the end of the line
right
unfortunately after B5 Knight takes B5
and then we can Castle but then the
Knight comes around and takes the pawn
on D4 and our Queen is actually trapped
there
Our Queen is actually trapped in that
position
so I have an idea
but this is like the flimsiest of
possible ideas it's interesting though
we're gonna go B5
we're gonna go B5
now first of all it's not a given that
our opponent sees Knight takes B5 you
know all these mini tactics are are not
that easy to spot you know for for
players in in this rating range but thus
far our opponent has shown quite an
ability to navigate the complexity at a
at a Grand Master Level
um and Knight takes B5 is no exception
my idea was Bishop to D7 I actually
think this is a very clever concept
folks so give this give this a chance
Bishop D7
okay now I thought I might win a piece
here Queen takes D7 and and the Knights
is now hanging we are threatening to
capture it with our Queen
let's see what I missed here
let's see what I missed here I mean I'm
sure it's winning somehow but
the thing is we are threatening to take
the Knight with our Queen
and it's not so easy to defend the night
I mean white can play the move C4 but
then already we castle and White's
pieces get very loose
oh I see there's the move Knight B5 I
think to C3
which I'm sure our opponent probably saw
a mile away but it listen it leads to an
end game
and end games even completely lost Ones
lead to Long games long games allow us
to milk some clock
and perhaps we can embark on a
on a campaign of trying to milk White's
clock down I mean we've already gotten
like four minutes off of it
which against an opponent of this
caliber is quite the achievement
let's see what our opponent comes up
with here
and for those watching on YouTube and
kind of rolling their eyes and being
like why am I not saying what's on
everybody's mind again if you haven't
seen my previous videos I have a very
strict policy for games in which players
play suspiciously where I you know I
don't comment on their play as long as
the game is going when the game ends I
share my thoughts but first and foremost
we look at the game carefully with an
engine we give everybody the benefit of
the doubt again always the thought
experiment you should do is like what if
you just played the best game of your
life like you most of you have played 99
accuracy games you cannot like how would
you feel if you were the person who has
just played a perfect game and 3 000
people are shouting that you're a
cheater right you would not
want to be treated that way
um and I really believe in putting
yourself in someone else's shoes with
that said I'm not going to let people
slide if it's obvious that they're
cheating but we're first going to
investigate carefully with an engine
that's how you have to do it
not trying to Virtue signal here that's
truly what I believe in
um because there are truly many
instances where somebody has preparation
or you think that they're cheating but
then you check with the engine and
they're actually not playing top
computer moves that also happens but
you've gotten it in your head that
they're cheating
so it's it's super important I think not
to do this
so our opponent is thinking he's deep in
the thought we're actually making some
progress on milking the clock
I really think Knight C3 is the only
move what's interesting is there's this
move Knight B5 to D6 check
and what happens in that line Knight D6
check we play Bishop takes D6
and the Queen on A4 is hanging
so if we calculate that line Knight D6
check Bishop takes D6 Queen takes queen
king takes Queen
Bishop takes Bishop King takes Bishop
we're up a knight
and in that resulting position there is
a fork E5 check but that pawn is
undefended we can just take it
if we added upon on F4
then this line actually would have
worked and liquidated into a winning
Rook end game probably
uh DK guy is asking is okay Knight C3
found
by our opponent
so we have no choice at this point so
first of all we cannot take the Knight
because the pawn is pinned everybody
should see that we have to trade Queens
because the Queens are in contact and we
our Queen is pinned
so we have two ways of doing this we can
try to Castle but that makes no sense to
me
because
that gives white an even better version
of this winning end game so we should at
least take
okay
and now we should make a decision there
is of course Knight takes C4 but the
reason Knight takes E4 doesn't work
is because of Rook H to E1
and the pressure down the e-file is way
way way too powerful I think
yeah it is actually it's not as easy as
it may seem there to
finish me off I think the alternative is
again to Castle
there's also the move Rook C8 here try
to hit the bishop but the bishop can
just drop back to E5 that's actually
even even better Square than C7
so that's counterproductive we're gonna
be down three pawns if we Castle so
Knight takes C4 might be the Practical
attempt
against
you know a how do I put this delicately
against another player I might play
Knight 64 but in the interest of
prolonging the game I'm going to Castle
try to get our opponent to use clock
which unfortunately he has stopped doing
okay
um well let's bring the Rook into the
game not much that we can do here other
than just sort of sort of sit around and
wait for white to convert his three
extra Pawns
but another note that I'll make as
you're watching this is that if you are
trying to figure out if someone's
cheating don't resign out of disgust
actually try to play real chess because
you're gonna actually build up evidence
okay so if he is cheating then a 50 move
game is usually a lot more compelling
than a 10 move game where you just
resigned because you're disgusted
so so play real chess and this is what
I'm doing here I'm bringing my Rooks
into the game I'm trying my best we're
just down three puns that's the reason
black is lost our pieces are actually
the best that they have been all game
long
but you're you know at this point we're
waging two different battles where
obviously trying to gauge our opponent's
play and I'm still trying to save this
end game
right because on the off chance that
white actually starts playing
in a semi-flawed manner
we will have a chance okay so we've
gotten white to think again we've gotten
white to spend half of his time
so maybe if we can make another 23 moves
we'll have a shot
although something tells me it's not
really the case Knight C3 good move
so what we want to avoid here with black
are trades right we want to keep as many
pieces on the board as possible for as
long as possible
and in the interest of avoiding trades
we don't want to go Bishop C5 here
because of Rook to DH check
all right so we basically just want to
sit around and wait and for that reason
I'm going to play King H7
um so that so that when we move our
Bishop Rook d8 is no longer going to be
a check it's still probably going to
force the Rook trade and it's obviously
still winning there's just not much that
I can do here
common misconception like I'm a GM you
know people think that it's it's
impossible to bring GMS down they never
die but there are certain positions
where
you see what I see it's not like I see
something special here and oh I'm gonna
create chances like basically black just
needs to sit around and wait and I hope
that white makes a blunder which is
increasingly unlikely Knight H5 only
move
okay this targets the bishop so okay
Rook D7
okay let's go Bishop B4
still trying
um I've drawn these types of positions
in Blitz that's for sure but
as I've tried to explain many times and
I might do a video on this actually I've
never done a video on
on I've talked about this on stream a
lot and that's the concept of like how
do I know when someone's cheating you
know what stands behind my intuition
that someone's not playing honestly
and part of it is this feeling I always
refer to that you're playing against a
wall right you're no matter what you
come up with your opponent has the
perfect response available to it
uh in response to it and it's just like
this total feeling of hopelessness
that's really hard to actually quantify
it's just a feeling you get born of oh
you know a lot of experience we're gonna
go rookie eight here try to take on G3
and win back at least one of the Pawns
and I'm definitely getting that feeling
very strongly in this game from the very
opening moves like from the very moment
that our opponent blitzed out that crazy
preparation rookie two yeah I mean
I'm gonna try to blockade with rookie
six notice that I'm trying to play Super
resiliently not giving our opponent an
easy job
but of course white is totally winning
because he's just up three pawns King D2
F4 maybe even F4 immediately I mean
that's what I would play but that's
that's a GM move F4 because you have to
give up a pawn
and people don't like giving up their
extra Pawns
and then just push F5 and E6 and whites
Black's position is blown to Smithereens
there
yeah and a clinical says best thing I've
heard someone say is a feeling of a
noose being tightened from all
directions exactly
and this is the feeling I'm getting
right look at this play on all sides of
the board King B2 Chase The Rook away
okay I oblige I oblige
we have to move
the last thing we want to do is take the
bishop unless we're absolutely oh so
this was the idea it was to chase The
Rook away and now to play F4 just
Exquisite technique
is white actually winning with correct
play dude why is white winning look at
the position look at the position he's
up three Pawns
okay King G6
let's try
we are trying to build a blockade on
this Square
and I think at this point it's not
I think F4 was was maybe a mistake and
see this is the exact point I'm trying
to make here
there is a chance that it's just that he
prepped really well
and he's trying his best and he's
actually playing Super well so
we just have to complete the game and
take it in stride
before we make any conclusions
now King G6 is a really strong move by
the way I think from our perspective
because we're actually going to plant
the King on F5 and it's not going to be
that easy for white to dislodge that
King we're gonna go King F5
okay White's down to six minutes we're
actually
making some progress I think if we can
get white down to like two minutes he
might maybe start start panicking I
don't know we'll see
but look at look at what I'm trying to
do I'm putting my king on F5 the reason
this was necessary is because if we
didn't do that white would have just
pushed F5 and then pushed E6 and clearly
that is game over
so if white can get our King off of F5
then the game ends if white can push F5
virtually in any version it's it's over
so we're just gonna try to keep this
King here for dear life there's also the
past C Pawn but that pawn isn't really
going anywhere at the moment so
amazingly okay King B3
King B3
okay well
I don't see exactly what this does
yeah we can play G5 here and try to
disrupt the I don't know about G5 I mean
a lot of these moves are basically
equivalent
um well Rook F7 repeats moves that leads
to a draw white obviously does not want
to draw
um okay I guess we can double on the C
file
to maybe prevent the move C4
just again trying to make this as
difficult as possible for our opponent
to milk milk a lot of clock
he's down at five minutes so it's
starting to get just a little bit
interesting here
but it's just 15 plus 10 is so much time
that you can basically afford to think
as long as you want on every move
I if I if somebody put a knife to my
throat right now I would say that he
probably hasn't used the engine in a
hundred percent of moves
but has likely done it in like of
frequent it has done it frequently this
game but we'll see again no need to
speculate when we have the engine let's
continue defending
gracefully
and already I think Rook F7 check is a
sign
that our opponent might be struggling
just a bit we've taken another minute
off his clock by the way and Rook B6
check is a threat that forces the king
onto the corner file
so wait a second wait a second this
actually
wait a minute that was a Mist definitely
must be a mistake by him
um wait this has gotten interesting all
of a sudden we can push his moves to
this we can push his King to the side
and it's almost mate
um
pause champ
so do you guys see what I'm saying you
can go Rook V6 or even Rook B8
it's almost it's already almost a draw
wait let me calculate let me calculate
for a second God there's got to be
something already at this point
it's still
a
little
afraid
it's still losing
but not by much
yeah it's definitely still lost
because the king runs to A5 okay so
here's my idea
all right well um
crud let's start with the check
let's start with the chuck
yeah if I can pull out a draw in this
game I'll be like the happiest person in
the world
so here's what I'm calculating folks
I assume our opponent will go King A4 it
would be wild to play King A3 in this
position although anything is possible
but King A3 allows an additional check
on C3 I don't know any person in the
universe would play King A3 here
um King A4 is logical
then what I was calculating is Rook to
C4 check which I know all of you see
King A5
Rook C4 King A5 Rook B5 King takes A6 or
K4 Checkmate except it's not Checkmate
because the Rook on B5 has lost its
support so there's no way to ladder
Checkmate I don't see anything we can
try the move Rook B5 now
to cut the king off from the fifth rank
but that's slow right Rook B5 is slow
and white we've given white a Tempo that
he can use to for example play Rook to
E4
so I have an interesting idea well I
don't want to play Rook take C6 because
that relinquishes the net that we have
woven over White's King I'm going to
make a move that you might find
confusing
I'm gonna go Knight H5 to F6
but the idea is very straightforward
we're attacking all of a sudden White's
King is under attack this has gotten
exciting
and when you're attacking the first rule
of attack is that you want to bring
pieces into the attack into the game
and that's what we're doing we're trying
to bring the Knight desperately quickly
as quickly as possible
into the attack via D5 now what is it
doing on D5 you may ask well it's it
would be protecting
it would be protecting
The Rook okay I don't get this move we
can just take it I think can't we
what happens if I take
wait let's think
I think we have to take because if we
don't it just goes Rook C7
takes E7 oh and we're pinned
okay
um
no we're gonna try let's see what he
wants
yeah you guys are right I didn't see
seven from a distance
we can try rugby five
maybe he promotes
photography five actually this is a
super sexy move
Rook B5 is a Super Saiyan No rookie six
loses on the spot rookie six
he takes it and goes rookie eight
or goes work F2 we don't want to leave I
mean
I mean a lot of flares would promote
here you know
a lot of people would promote in this
position
but obviously this guy is not a lot of
people
No rookie five doesn't work
rookie five I take it
that actually doesn't work no I have
managed to create Mega complications in
this position
but unfortunately the time control is so
vast that like he still has three
minutes left
whoa Bishop E1
okay
stopping the check on C3 cold-blooded
cold-blooded
that is a dank ass move right there we
gotta go back to E8 with our Rook
that is that is just that is a standard
1300 level movie a bishop
G3 to E1 yep
mm-hmm
we've gotten them down two minutes 40
seconds it's still the game is still
going
yeah Bishop E1 is a very standard move
for his level as is yeah and now c4
okay Rook C5 it is
still in it still in it
give me at least the problem is he
starts playing he actually like
is playing quite fast
and I guess he's just gonna take now
foreign
but um
we'll see
yeah he whooped me
this doesn't look like the top like the
best move
here I check and go King G6 no what am I
missing
King G6
still in it
this does not look like the the best
move what he just did there
okay Rook Cafe yeah he's man I'm
impressed that he's actually managed to
play fast
and I guess C5
wow wait
let's try to defend from behind with
rookie two
there's still a chance I mean there's a
chance that he plays a move quickly
and blunders there's definitely still a
shot in this game
A4
all right King B6 and it's winning
wait it's not over yet
it's not over yet
yeah fell for it
not only is it not over yet I might not
even be winning so let's uh temper our
celebrations
let's temper our celebrations
yeah I think it's winning
I think it's winning but listen this
Pawn can hardly be stopped so what do we
do here
what is Black's best move in this
position let's go back to speedrun mode
we've allowed ourselves a little too
much fun
96 yeah 96 C7 Knight takes C7
oh I figured out the win
I figured out the win
and it is Knight takes C7
and now
I think we have a genius move
no we're winning and the genius move is
A5 very nice you guys got it so there's
two scenarios here scenario one is where
we take on G2
and white takes on A6
um the problem in that scenario is that
white is going to promote the a pawn
we're going to have to give the Rook up
for the a pawn so we need to win the a
pawn at all cost how do we win the a
pawn well we need to fix it on a light
Square so we play A5 here
and then we go Rook to C4 so watch this
one king up to B6 Rook down to C4
and the King cannot go up to B5 because
that blunders the bishop on C7 and we
win
unbelievable now again there's a lot to
talk about here a lot to talk about
I want to repeat that I am not throwing
out any accusations
um our opponent's play was highly
suspicious we can all agree on that no
matter where you stand on the whole
cheating question we can agree that the
play was odd it's rare for me to be
outplayed by a 1300 not impossible
everything in chess is possible but it's
rare so we need to check the game
carefully with an engine there's also a
chance that our opponent was stream
sniping because a lot of the time I said
a move it corresponded with it being
played
um let's push our Pawn maybe to A4
I think we should actually start with
King G5
so
we need to operate purely based on what
the engine reveals
yeah
that was a crazy game and I have a
feeling that our opponent may have been
sniping because this was a crazy
coincident I literally said King B6 as a
last ditch effort in case our opponent
is listening to the Stream
um let's go King H4 this is the easiest
we just take around and win the puns
Bishop oh I blundered
wait actually I didn't blunder just I
didn't blunder but
actually I missed this move this is
another nice move
so we go g okay actually wait this is an
instructive moment
how what we need to do is we need to
eliminate both of these pawns while
keeping at least one of our pawns alive
so the way we do that is we play G5
we play G5
and then we don't play King takes H3
here
no no no because then we give up the G5
phone we could end up losing the a pawn
and that's a draw so what's the move
here it's not A4 forget the a pawn we
don't need the a pawn
that pawn can go to can go you know take
a walk
what we yeah so what we just need to do
Rook A3 Rook H2 we win the H Pawn with a
rook
so that the king can maintain contact
with the Jeep on then we take G4 and
White's King is going to be way too far
away to stop the G Pawn that's it the
game is over
of course Rook H2 is also similarly
winning you don't even need the a pawn
this would be completely winning without
the a pawn
that's it and it will be completely
winning without the Apon
yeah table based dry yeah we just move
the gang and promote
bang making sure that we're not
blundering the pawn
right it took me a second there and just
push push push
push push
and Rook H1
G1 quick and you there is a way to do
this so that you intercept the bishop
but it doesn't matter you just go and
make a queen
what a game what a game oh this is gonna
be this is gonna be a like my most
viewed speedrun video probably which is
kind of sad in a way but I kind of get I
think of jolia for the five Subs so
we're gonna start in this case
by running the game through the engine
briefly and this is not part of our
analysis there we are also going to
analyze this game
but we are going to begin with a just a
sort of overview of our opponent's play
now notice the the accuracy might be
completely messed up because of the huge
blunder so I wouldn't put too much stock
here
in the accuracy
that's sort of the caveat
I would not put too much stock in in the
accuracy
but nonetheless we will start by
checking
and if we want to do this really
properly we would do this on the
stockfish engine on chess base which is
what we're going to do so I'm going to
check the accuracy
and then we're actually going to do this
properly plugging in the game into chess
base
um where I have a much stronger engine
and an engine that will go up to a
certain depth
so we're going to do it in a moment
let's let the the the machine run
so as this loads you know this is the
speed run the emphasis is on
instructive value so to those who are
watching this and are feeling a little
underwhelmed at my lack of explanations
I do apologize for that but this is a
kind of a hopefully an extenuating
circumstance I will explain a lot of
stuff in short order
but this is still part of your overall
chess Improvement right knowing how to
deal with these types of players knowing
the signs how how to act in these cases
is I think very important
um
okay so 82.5 and again you can see that
there was one blunder and that blunder
was King B6 says zero mistakes
four and I also says I had zero mistakes
so it actually says I have higher
accuracy this makes no sense right you
can just a priori this makes no sense
you know that because white was winning
completely the entire game right so the
accuracy it just doesn't make and it's
skewed because of the blunder but white
blunder to full Rook
so what we do now is we plug the game
into chess base
we turn on stock Vision we quickly run
through it just kind of checking to see
how many top moves there were
this is not a scientific method of
Investigation
I'm not claiming that it is but we're
trying to give ourselves a better sense
okay
all right this should do
this should do
so let's examine
now first of all we need to analyze this
opening just independently of everything
and I have a feeling
yeah as far as I remember so here you
can see on the right hand side well
you're not actually seeing it but
stockfish at depth 46 says E6 is
equalizing so this is already a mistake
amazing D6 apparently is Adam is a
mistake
and it is because of this line Queen D4
E5
and now Queen B4 yeah so this is
apparently well known
yeah 43 games in the database wow so
this is a known line you see we have to
give our opponent the benefit of the
doubt H6
Bishop B3 still games in the database
Knight F6 still games in the database
and we can see Jasmine played this
Jasper had this in a title Tuesday game
Queen D7 castles and Jasmine played
exactly like I did we're following the
game incredible
um we're following it Jasper's title
Tuesday game you can actually see it a
little bit in the uh in the top when you
can see a five one game that's the
Jasper title Tuesday game
and just actually won which is crazy but
that's a moot point
so it's already plus four
now we check so D5
yeah so this is this next move is
incredibly suspicious Queen A5 I don't
know Queen B3 is more human to me so
Queen A5 is a top move
Knight takes C5 is basically a top move
now it's a top move
should be seven
Queen A4 check so this move
was not fantastic but not bad
so this is this does not spoil anything
B5 Knight B5 Knight D7 and Knight C3 but
these are all forced moves
these are all forced moves Rook D4 is
top
Bishop G3 was the second move Rook D1 is
top
Knight C3 is the second move
E5
is slight in accuracy
slide in accuracy but still it's plus
six so this is you cannot make any
conclusions in the base no Rook D7 is
the second move now
Rook F7 is the second move
okay but Rook D2 is obvious
rookie two is the first move
King B2
maintains the advantage yeah King B2 is
the second move now
F4
maybe not the most accurate but still
Rook B7 is good
so King B3 is a little bit inaccurate
game V3 is a little bit inaccurate and
actually G5 was a move here
Rook F7
okay so this is already
black is going white is going a little
bit astray
but F5 is okay
if I'm honest with you this was maybe
the most suspicious Moment Like F5
and D7 is is incredible
and Bishop E1
second move is Bishop E1 yeah
that's Bishop E1 is is an amazing move
I mean it's it's it makes sense
and C4 is good
Bishop G3 is also a good move
yeah Rook f8 is not perfect
but this is still completely winning oh
C5 is good
A4 is good
and it's completely winning after Rook
C8
yeah
um
so what conclusions can we draw from
this brief
uh run through well first of all
knowing that line as you know 1300 is is
is is exceedingly rare but we again
it's not impossible maybe he looked this
up maybe this is his his Jam right his
line
it could be another Smurf so there's an
option that this is a Smurf and his real
strength based on this game I would
estimate at 24 2500 feet a but at 2400
would never ever ever in a 15-minute
game blunder King B6 so that's what
doesn't add up and that's what tells me
maybe he was stream sniping because I
deliberately said King B6 I did this
twice the first time I think he didn't
buy it the first time was when in this
position I said Knight takes D5 is
winning it was a troll obviously
the second time it actually did work
so
he's up to something I'm pretty sure of
that
but my standard for these videos is like
if he's watching this video
I'm hoping that he would find my
perspective to be reasonable
like we looked over the game
this was an incredibly well played game
it's virtually unprecedented for 1300 to
be able to play a game like this
um so there's never any like do I have
any cold hard proof no
um
but
you know this is this is what I can say
okay
but nonetheless there's no no direct
accusations we just looked over the game
I expressed my suspicions and that's
that
chess.com always investigates fairly and
you know I'm gonna let that let them do
that
let's analyze the game
so we're actually going to analyze it in
chess space
I actually like this layout the reason
we're going to do that is because this
was an engine heavy game and it's
sensible for us to use stockfish we're
gonna we're gonna deviate from
our Golden Rule which is to never use
the engine explicitly in analysis
but this game was so technical there was
so much going on that I think it just
makes sense to focus on the opening
phase
and make sure that we know how to play
against Bishop B5 remember that that is
the goal of the speed Earnest to develop
a full opening repertoire so that's what
we're going to focus on
um so let's rewind back to the start
so Knight C3 now it's important to
realize what I said
when this game was starting which is
that if you are a accelerated Dragon
player
and you want to go Knight C6 if you're a
knight or a player you want to go D6
right because if white goes Knight F3
and doubles back to the open system you
want to be able to play a night ORF
now conversely sorry the dragon works
the same exact way right Knight C6 if
White NOW goes Knight up let me just go
G6
and you play an accelerate it and I just
anti-selling is anything that's not the
open Sicilian
now if you're a knight or a flare and
you suddenly face this line there's no
way to get back into the night ORF now
you can play the move E5 here to keep
the non-open Sicilian flavor but the
latest verdict on this line which is a
very popular line I don't like this for
black I feel like this is a very very
hard line to play although it's highly
theoretical and it's in it and it's been
played by a ton of GMS so hopefully that
makes sense if you are a con Sicilian
player then of course you should play
E60 which is a great move by the way E6
against the close Sicilian is I think
maybe even the best line but you have to
be ready to face Knight F3 and then
you're basically move ordered either
into a con or a tamanov So based on what
you play you should play that
appropriate move here we played Knight
C6 and we're facing Bishop B5 so Knight
T4 is the topical move and after Knight
F3 let's see what the engine
can um bring to the table here so as far
as I remember
I think the best line is actually to
play A6 here that's what the engine
seems to be giving this for A6
if Bishop C4 then we can actually play
B5
and we're not afraid of Bishop D5 we
just go Rook B8 so you have to be ready
in this line to play creatively and to
delay your development by a little while
okay
why is this good for black because we're
gonna play E6 with Tempo on the next
move and the bishop is just going to be
stupid on this diagonal and if white
takes and drops the Knight back
and look at this with Knight F6
Knight takes D4 on and this is simple we
take on D5
and then we go Bishop B7 fianchettoing
and winning the pawn back
with interest
so if white goes D6 then we just go E6
and we pick up the pawn like this
obviously we don't take
that looks terrible and if Queen F3 we
go E6
using tactics to win the pawn back
if Queen H5
then we go Rook C8 this is really this
is really pretty and Rook C5 we win the
pawn back like this
everything looks easy when you're
analyzing with the engine
so you have to toe the line a little bit
in this line
but nobody's gonna go Bishop C4 people
go Bishop D3 here that is the main move
this I remember and now E6 so you set up
essentially a con setup but because this
is not an open Sicilian you shouldn't be
afraid of playing this
if white takes and goes 92 this is a
very important now I'm starting to
remember this analysis in this position
you do not go Bishop C5 because then the
bishop is not positioned very well
you go D5 you go D5 and how does this
work well what happens if white plays
Knight takes D4 black plays d e
and wins one of the minor pieces you see
that right so the human move here I
think is E5
but now this Pawn is undefended this
Pawn is undefended Queen G5 Fork
and again we're getting away with making
this many moves with non-minor pieces
because look at how passively White's
developed the bishop on C1 is blocked in
We're Not Afraid our fund our structures
sound here
F4 white can try
let me just drop our Queen back and if
flight pushes we just go E5 and this is
even better for black
does this make sense I I hope this is
making sense like I have all these moves
and so far all of these moves to me are
like perfectly sensible it's just a lot
of concrete stuff you have to remember
here and if Ed then Queen takes D5 let's
say White Castles and at this point I
think it makes sense to start developing
the engine likes Bishop D7 Bishop C6 I
like the move Knight F6 here I think
this is simple
and black is a perfectly good position
here
so this is how you analyze with an
engine you don't just suppress the space
bar which gives you the next engine move
you actually try to understand why each
move is played so for example even here
right why Bishop D7 and not Knight F6
why is the engine prefer this move right
well what you do is you say after Knight
F6 what is the move well the move is C3
then you ask yourself well why is the
same move not good after the engine's
recommendation
and you're saying ah well black has this
move Bishop C6
okay well why is Bishop C6 so strong
well it threatens Checkmate and why is
it bad for white to play F3 now Knight
F6 and the idea starts to crystallize
the idea starts to crystallize after
Knight takes D4 you have Bishop to C5
and here you see the damage that white
has done himself by playing F3
and we're able to win the pawn back with
interest
compare that long line with Knight F6
and now C3 we don't have the equivalent
idea if we play Bishop D7 here in Bishop
C5 we can still do that but there's no
pin anymore and actually the knights
still can't move but it's just not quite
as effective
okay so Bishop D7 is actually the most
accurate move here fascinating
okay so that was an exploration of
Knight 64. the main move as far as I
remember for white is just a castle and
here I really like how the computer
handles this it's suggesting to just
drop the Knight back to C6 and say hey
your Bishop on D3 looks really really
stupid I don't want to have anything to
do with this Knight C6 is what's been
played against me when I played this
line with white
and after Bishop E2
we can go back to D4 I mean this is a
repetition that could happen
um because if white takes here the
Knight is nowhere good to go it doesn't
have E2 anymore
and remember that in this position
uh there is this very typical maneuver
where you go 97 and then Knight to C6 in
order to protect this Pawn
and this Pawn is a strength right it's
it's lording over the whole position
so there is the possibility of repeating
moves
but there is also the possibility
um in this position let's see if there
are alternatives to Knight D4 let's say
you don't want to repeat moves
wow look at the second recommendation G5
I actually kind of like this move
and the idea should be obvious you're
basically going for the attack you're
going for the day you're preventing D4
G5 is a prophylactic move that's all it
is that's all it is and it's an idea
that exists across a lot of different
lines it's been very popular to play G5
in these types of positions let me give
you an example there is a line in the
bishop B5 check Sicilian the Moscow
variation
where oh my headphones turned off just a
second
so let me remember it's this
no no no no it's it's A6 Bishop D3
and there's a G5 here let me check
it's not G5 here God damn there's a line
where black goes G5
here
it's not here
I'm trying to remember I I swear there's
a line where black goes G5 and it's very
similar to this
so this this
[Music]
How does it go
here
here no no it's it's C3
oh I remembered it's C4 yes and now 55
games that G5 is the most popular move
in this position there we go and
famously uh Alex Sasha grishek was one
of the first people to play this in
2015. vesseline De paulov played this
for the first time ever against Magnus
and one in the singfield cups apollov
beat Carlson with black in this line
worth checking out if you're interested
just search up that game
um in any case I'm I'm digressing now
the engine
is no longer a fan of this but that's
not the point as you can understand
imagine facing this for the first time
ever and in 2015 maybe engines were
approving and the point of G5 here is a
little bit different you're trying to go
G4 but you're also trying to get white
to release the E5 square and of course
of course of course you're trying to
open the G file for attack
so you can check out this game but the
bottom line is that G5 is it sounds
crazy but it's a common idea in many
different types of openings of course in
the French
this is also ridiculously common
in many cases in the tarash French you
get a situation where basically
after Knight gf3 there's even the move
G5 in this position this exists
and the idea is to push G4 again a
different reason you're trying to weaken
White's control over D4 but remember
that if you see a move that sounds that
looks crazy chances are it's actually
standard fare in a lot of different
positions also you're sort of preparing
to fee and keto the bishop so it's like
an extended fiancado now the engine
gives an edge for white after this first
on Knight D2 is not necessarily a human
move I would be more inclined to play 91
to keep the dark squid Bishop open but
apparently after H5 already even
objectively black is better because
white is so cramped
so apparently Knight D2 is the top
engine move and now we go H5 I would
like to have this with black this looks
fun nobody's gonna play F3 here that's a
weird McQueeney one what are these moves
I feel like the human move here
is like Knight C4 and immediately white
is much worse I guess Knight C4 gets
chased away maybe Knight B3 to open the
bishop
Queen C7 typical move in the Sicilian
con getting the queen on a nice square
and then Bishop D6 to aim at the H2 Pawn
so let's say Bishop B3 Bishop D6
it's just a very tactical position a
super risky line but something worth
playing if you're facing a lower rated
opponent because this is how quickly it
can get bad G3 H4
and already black is winning because you
have this sack on G3 it's not really a
sack and black is a massive attack
FG Queen G3 is checkmate
okay so we just discovered is this a
novelty let's check
let's check if this is a novelty
it is not it's been played and it's been
played by GM's sarich played this in
2003 somebody played it Anatoly weisser
uh played and guess what I was right
uh Knight D2 was played three times
but by correspondence players 91 is what
the humans played
so javanovic Grand Master
um okay F3 was played by baklan 2600.
weisser responded with Bishop D6 the
game from 2003.
and in this position apparently black is
supposed to drop the bishop back and
pave the way for D5 but already black is
better
in the other human game Bishop B3 was
played by a GM
by a GM and after D5 apparently white
black is already much better
so what this tells you is that the human
value of this line is incredibly High
most humans who've all of the humans who
have had this have gotten terrible
positions with white Bishop G7
attacking D4 and if DC then D4 Forks the
bishop in the knife so we have
discovered already a very interesting
line and so the way to play this line in
conclusion is to start with A6 we
examine Bishop C4
Bishop D3 is the main line now we go E6
we don't fear Knight D4 because here we
have this D5 idea with Queen G5 against
E5
and if castles we drop the Knight back
to C6
now should Bishop B2 we can repeat moves
against the high rated opponent or we
can play G5 with the idea of G4 and H5
now there's also the move B3 here that
I've played with white
but B3 as far as I remember you can just
go G6
and counteract White's Bishop with your
own Bishop typical developing now Knight
A4 I've had this against men actually
where we trade Bishops like this
and I'm pretty sure Min correctly plays
D6
Rook you one end E5 just pushed the pawn
through grab the center and black is a
great position here Knight F6 Castle the
D5 score is weak but it cannot really be
occupied by a piece
so wild complications but black is
totally comfortable here so Knight takes
B5 by Me was actually an inaccuracy you
can see stockfish kind of goes up
it still says it's equal but it I
already felt very very risky apparently
the correct move here no sorry is E6
and apparently this version is playable
after B5 wow
but this looks scary doesn't it I mean
this looks even scarier than the game
continuation Bishop G5 with tempo
uh now it was 97 blocking the bishop
yeah this is computer play
so at a Grand Master Level what you
often do and the misconception is that
GMS just plug positions into the engine
and that's how you make a file no see it
says equal but I would never ever
recommend for anybody to go for this
position with black in a game
how do I know that just intuitive feel
it looks horrible
it just looks a knight D5 there might be
some sacrifices in on D5 with even
though it's give zeros
I mean if you actually just look at the
line F6 is the only move nobody would
ever play that
because if you play Bishop B7 then
already it's plus minus so you have to
decide when you're analyzing with an
engine also using your field are you
actually comfortable playing the
position at the end of the day you have
to be the one
being comfortable with a position and if
for whatever reason you don't feel
comfortable you feel like you won't be
able to handle the resulting middle game
in a game then you shouldn't play the
line you should search until you find
stuff that you actually feel comfortable
with and that's what we did here
so after d64 and queen D4 apparently
black is already clearly worse and it's
due to this crazy move Queen B4
um pokra asks as a low rated player why
does playing against long cast like this
feels here well it's less that you see
it it's less that you're playing against
long castle and more that you're behind
massively in development white has
already castled and gotten all of his
minor pieces out and you've gotten no
minor pieces out black can't move here
right you can't move this bishop because
you dropped G7 and if you have to make a
super weakening move like F6 in order to
survive well that's a bad sign that's a
sign this position is super hard to
handle
so now you might see but but isn't it
equal it is but only with like insanely
precise engine moves that I wouldn't be
comfortable forcing myself to find
I I hope this this makes sense like I'm
trying to explain and give you like a
meta strategy for analyzing with an
engine since we're already on this kind
of General topic
um
so anyways D6 D4 so why is Queen B4 such
a strong move well it's because of the
ensuing idea of putting the bishop on B6
this idea is insanely strong if white
goes anywhere except before then black
is fine you can see the engine gives
even slight Edge for black and H6 is
what I was planning to play and then uh
Knight F6 now this is what I call the
Smith Law idea if you play Knight F6
immediately this is inaccurate because
of Bishop G5 takes F6 and then Knight D5
this idea of removing a Defender
and then occupying the square with the
Knight
is most famously Illustrated
in a game played in the 40s by Vasily
smithslava Soviet world champion
now this is a very
um famous game that's been shown way too
many times it's not the only
illustration of this topic and I've
shown this before in the speed run but
hey
you got to look at stuff that you
already know that's part of what
learning is all about
so Smith's love had this position just a
moment
there we go
now stockfish is off which is why you
have this weird panel
what does Smith's Love play in this
position what's going on well you should
see the similarity there is a weak
Square on D5
but that square is defended by Black's
Knight
so Smith's Love Goes Bishop G5 very
famously
then he eliminates the Knight
and then he positions his own Knight on
D5
and this actually uses some tactics to
make it work if Queen takes C2
you might notice that there is a
forkable square on C7 right
so this is a trick question what is
White's best move
there is a mukwa the most popular wrong
answer and the map was very instructive
and then there's the correct move
let's see who can avoid the trick
so
most of you are like Rook C1 it's Rook
C1
but see this is I call this queen
disease when you
when you don't realize that you've given
up a thousand pieces for your queen it's
the same exact concept here when you're
winning an exchange right you have to
realize that an exchange is not that
much material so what you're doing is
you're giving away
a crap ton of Pawns here on the queen
side and what's their material count at
the end well black has three pawns for
the exchange
this is not impressive but what you have
to notice is that Black's Queen
basically has to keep in contact with
the C7 squared must stay on the C file
so what move can we start with to
prevent Queen takes B2 from being a
thing it's Rook F2 excellent now notice
that Bishop H4 there's always the move
G3 I know some of you might be thinking
what about that move no
the queen has to move on the C file
now again we use the same principle Rook
C1 again is premature because if Queen
takes A2 so again we played B3 we just
keep chasing the queen down the C file
and only when we're ready do we play
Rook C1 and Knight C7
okay
so
hopefully that made sense
so this is this Miss love idea
um
this idea has been applied
ad nauseam
in a gazillion different types of
situations
I've had it played against me many times
an example I have shown before on stream
is this game against kudron kudrin being
a typical Russian GM that I that I faced
uh
quite a few times when I was like 22
2300
so kudrin
um
had this position against me I was black
again same opening night ARF right and
this structure very often occurs in the
nighter so it's not a coincidence that
that you actually get this often and of
course he goes Bishop to G5
same drill eliminating the Knight
I took on A2
so he just takes and goes back
doesn't give a damn and eventually okay
here he makes an amazing move I love
this next move he plays this is so
freaking instructive
so what move do you want to play but
can't and why can't you play it logical
thinking is a great exercise in logical
thinking
and like actually calculating so you
want to play Knight D5 right
and by the way a rook on D5 is still a
sexy P this is a nice output but you you
don't want to give up C2 because the
whole Queen side collapses so you might
say okay well let's defend the C2 pawn
and I think most of you are probably oh
let's go Queen D2
the problem with Queen D2 is the black
goes Rook ACA and again you're in
trouble because you have to move the
Knight of C2
so kujin plays a classic Grand Master
move who can find it
and there's two moves that do the same
thing but he makes the more elegant move
so most of you if I read you guys right
are thinking Rook ac1
but he goes Rook A2
and well what the heck is the difference
well Rook ac1 is inferior for a variety
of reasons The Rook on C1 is totally
tied down to the pawn
the rokade2 is preparing in for the
event that white plays well B5 is played
A5
and The Rook I need to now defends the
A5 pawn and the C2 pawn and later on
further down the line when wine moves
the night away maybe he can push the
pawn out of C2 and then double on the
default so The Rook on A2 is just better
placed and finally he achieves his aim
he gets his Rook to D5 and he proceeds
to outplay me now watch what he does
now I mentioned that the Rook on D5 was
a good piece but what piece do you
really want to go to D5 well it's the
Knight watch what he does bang
he goes Queen E4
Bang
C3 and look at this
his Rook I need to is actually doing
something now it's defending F2 that was
a very prophetic move
you see many moves later it's actually
coming handy the fact that he's put the
Rook on A2 this is the Elegance of
positional play you do stuff
for the future now you don't know if the
future is ever going to turn into
reality but one time out of three it
does
and now 93 and Knight C5 and he has
fully completed positional domination
and he proceeded to win the game but all
of this stemmed from The Smith's love
idea Bishop G5
okay so maybe I belabored this but now
you'll never forget it hopefully
now you'll fully understand this concept
of eliminating a piece to access the
square
um
okay so back we go
to the game
and we're going to turn stockfish on
again
just because we've been analyzing the
engine
and that's fine with me
so instead that's why we want to go H6
here so that after Castle's night I'm
saying white can still put the 995 but
here the worst piece to occupy an
outpost with is the queen
okay
um because why well because the queen is
ridiculously vulnerable and we can chase
the queen away first by putting our
Queen on C7 not this because it blunders
B7 but first queen C7 wow you're added
you can hit the pawn and then Bishop E6
and Bishop E7 are the great position
so this would have been fine Queen B4 is
incredibly strong now the engine gives
us some ways that we could survive this
I'm not particularly interested because
we've already extracted the lessons from
the opening apparently H6 makes things
even worse and after Knight F6 it's
officially a losing position it's
already plus two
apparently the only move here was was in
fact to play Queen E7 castles and
somehow to to just pretend that
nothing's the matter but this position
sucks now of course what I had missed
from a distance I thought that I would
go here
and notice that if white doesn't have
Knight takes E5 black is fine but white
has this incredibly annoying move 95 and
this is crushing because the queen is
trapped the queen is literally trapped
you have to take and then you get
checkmated
um well the jaspin game is a title
Tuesday game so it's not not that
interesting
um and the crazy thing is that if you
develop and you say I have an idea well
now Knight takes E5 is not possible
because after d e we're attacking the
queen simultaneous we're going to win a
piece well you have to keep calculating
it is possible because after Rook D7
Mission before there is the check on DN
anyway and white wins h8
and White's up in exchange and winning
the game so all of these tactical lines
work perfectly in White's favor we had
to move our Queen again and Bishop C7 is
a sexy move just attacking from behind
and Black's position simply collapses
maybe King D7 could have been tried but
here there are more tactics with Rook
takes D6 and Rook D1 picking up the
queen with a devastating attack
and um there's just nothing that can be
done here here the position collapses
and nothing's developed and white is
just taking everything and checkmating
me down the D file and the rest of
course uh We've analyzed we're not going
to look at the end game in this video
we've already gone quite a while uh of
course white is totally winning I could
talk about you know more accurate less
accurate moves but at the end of the day
our opponent played very very well up
until uh blundering that fork so
I think this is we're gonna pause guys
I'm not sure how long this video is
going to last but quite an eventful
Speed Run game
I wasn't expecting something this crazy
but again our focus in the speedrun is
on opening so I hope that you enjoyed
the discussion of Knight C6 Bishop B5
and now you know how to play against it
uh well well now you know how to play
against Knight F3 there is also Bishop
C4 which is the old main line and I'm
quite sure that we're going to face this
line at least one more time so we're
going to get a chance to discuss this
Theory
later but I hope you enjoyed the game
this is slightly different method of
analysis we had the engine on
and I know some people are going to be
like where I want to have the engine on
you know but but hopefully you can
appreciate that we were focusing on
openings here
and obviously we were checking our
opponent's place so you know hope you
can forgive this deviation from the norm
and on that note folks it's almost five
hours I'm gonna call it a night
I will see y'all tomorrow
and I am going to raid
who am I going to rate I'm going to raid
Fiona Fiona covering the European rapid
Championship thank you all for hanging
out thanks for the support once again I
have a YouTube channel if you subscribe
you help me tremendously thank you
everybody goodbye
[Music]